[MUSIC PLAYING]
MISTRAL MYERS: Nathan's the
founder and executive director
of the nonprofit
I'm From Driftwood,
which you'll be
hearing about today,
which is an online archive of
first person LGBTQ stories.
In 2011, Manske completed a four
month 50 state story collection
tour, ensuring that I'm
From Driftwood stories
represented people from
all across the country.
The stories on
I'm From Driftwood
are used by family counselors
as well as educators
to aid them in their work, and
I'm From Driftwood's newest
program, which is
called What Was It Like,
documents stories from LGBTQ
elders, which, as you know,
is something that we have also
been looking at in the Gayglers
is understanding how to better
serve older LGBTQ folks.
Matthew grew up in Driftwood,
Texas, hence the name
I'm From Driftwood, where
one of his weekly chores
was burning trash in a
burn barrel, which I really
want to hear about.
He now lives in Brooklyn
where he sorts and recycles.
Thank you for saving the planet.
So, Nathan, tell
us a little bit now
that we know a little bit about
you about I'm From Driftwood.
NATHAN MANSKE: Yeah,
next month in March
is actually going to be our
nine year anniversary, which
we're very excited about.
The idea came to me from
after watching the film
"Milk" in 2008 with Sean
Penn, and I saw the film
on a Wednesday, and
Thursday morning, I
was thinking about a
photograph of Harvey Milk.
And in the photograph,
he's sitting
on the hood of the car in the
San Francisco pride march,
and he's holding a big
sign, and the sign,
all it said was "I'm
from Woodmere, New York."
And I was just thinking about
that photo over and over again
and asking myself like,
why is Harvey Milk--
everyone associates him with
San Francisco, this big queer
mecca.
But he's not from there.
He's sitting here proclaiming
that he's from this town that--
we're in New York, so some
people might know where it is,
but most people don't
know where Woodmere is.
And that really
resonated with me
because I'm not from
Brooklyn or New York.
I'm from Driftwood, Texas.
And I feel like that
message of you're
not alone no matter where
you are would have meant
a lot to me growing
up in Driftwood where
my main issue was isolation.
I didn't feel like--
or I did feel like I was the
only gay person in the world.
So that message of
you're not alone
would have meant a lot to me.
So I wanted to take that message
out there through storytelling.
And at the time, I was working
in advertising as a copywriter,
and I was worried that I
wouldn't have time to do this.
And so to recap, I saw
"Milk" on Wednesday.
I thought of the
idea on Thursday.
Friday, I went into my
job, and I was laid off.
So I suddenly had all the time
in the world to, you know.
It was late 2008,
height of the recession.
So there was little chance
to get a new job right away.
So I put everything I had
into it, told all my friends.
Everyone rallied around
me and helped launch
three months after thinking
of the idea in March 2009.
So, yeah, that's
how it came to be.
MISTRAL MYERS: Very cool.
All from a photograph.
So tell us a little bit
about what I'm From Driftwood
seeks to do.
What is the project about?
NATHAN MANSKE: It at its
core is about sending
that message of you're not
alone through storytelling,
and something really
interesting happened early on.
We started as just
written stories.
So anyone could write a
story-- and still can--
and submit their written story.
But it started really to help
queer youth in smaller towns.
That was my singular focus.
And after launching
the site, we started
getting all this feedback
from people letting
us know what the
stories meant to them,
and it wasn't just queer
youth in small towns.
It was people here in Manhattan.
It was people all over
the country and the world
letting us know that
just by hearing stories
from other people, whether
they connected with it or not,
made them more empathetic
to other issues.
And then, of course,
people did read stories
that they related
to, and it helped
them realize I'm not alone.
And there were two
pieces of feedback
that we got very early on
which made us realize that we
were on the right track.
One was from a gay
teenager who said
seeing these stories made him
realize that he's not alone
and that they literally
saved his life just
by realizing that
wherever he was
from that there are other
people like him out there.
The other one was from somebody
who was almost 60, and he said,
I thought I was the only one.
I'm not, and I just came
out this past Christmas
at the age of 60.
So once we realized that
we were making an impact
across the entire spectrum,
we broadened our reach,
but still with that message of
you're not alone, but no matter
who you are, where you
are, what age you are.
So, yeah, that's really what we
are still, but with a broader
message.
MISTRAL MYERS: That's
really interesting.
So you spoke a little
bit about the impact
that it's had on a
couple of individuals.
But can you speak more
broadly about the impact
that you feel the evolution
of this LGBTQ story archive
has had on your members'
readership, viewership?
NATHAN MANSKE: Yeah, I had
an intern a few years ago,
and I was still in
this mindset of--
especially since
we're a nonprofit so
we have to apply for funding
and all that fun stuff.
And constantly, we're
having to tell people
what we're doing is
so important and why.
And it was frustrating
and a little scary.
I was like, I can't
answer this succinctly.
Watch the story.
You'll get it.
But that's not an acceptable
answer on a grant application.
So I gave this intern
this task of researching
why stories are so powerful
and why they increase empathy.
We knew they did.
We have the feedback
to support it.
But I didn't
understand why, and it
felt like I was just
grasping for air,
and I couldn't sink my
teeth into an answer.
And what he came back with
was science, of course.
There's something called mirror
neurons in everyone's brain,
and whenever you
tell a story, you're
activating mirror neurons
in that person's brain.
So on a very
microscopic level, they
are experiencing the same
thing that you experienced.
So if I tell you
a story, and let's
just say our lives are
completely different,
and I tell you the story about
what it's like to grow up
gay in Driftwood, and
I tell a story well,
then I'm activating those
mirror neurons in your brain,
so that whenever you hear a
story like, ugh, I get it.
I feel you.
I'm in your shoes.
The reason for that is
those mirror neurons.
Since then, we have focused
more on telling stories well.
So every single story
that we collect and share,
we make sure that
there is a story arc.
There's a beginning,
middle, and end.
There's a conflict
and a resolution
and all these traditional
storytelling components
that make a story so that we can
activate those mirror neurons.
So we're basically
trying to control minds.
[LAUGH]
MISTRAL MYERS: Just a
simple, simple task.
NATHAN MANSKE: Yeah,
nothing difficult.
MISTRAL MYERS: Building
empathy in the world,
changing people's minds
about things, no big deal.
So how did the development
of I'm From Driftwood go?
Did it grow very, very quickly?
Were you surprised
by the growth,
or has it developed as a slow
burn over the time you've
been going?
NATHAN MANSKE: It was a little
bit of a roller coaster.
We launched just as a
website, and I didn't really
have this grand vision of what
it could become at the time.
I just wanted to start
collecting and sharing stories.
About a week after
launching, I was just
spending all my time emailing.
This was 2008 or 2009.
Everyone had a
blog at that time.
It was a blog heavy
time on the internet.
And there were a
lot of LGBT blogs,
and I was just emailing every
LGBTQ blog that I could find.
And a lot of them started
picking it up and sharing it,
and we just got a
wave of stories.
And soon after that, I had
a friend in Philadelphia--
his name is Marquise-- and I had
this idea of a little PR video
I wanted to do in New York.
I was going to walk around
the city with a white board
and have people write
where they're from,
just to get the
idea out there again
and another nod to that
photograph of Harvey Milk.
And he would visit
New York frequently,
and I told him this idea, and
he was like, oh, I'm into it.
But how about we have
people tell you a story?
And I'll film it and edit it.
And I was resistant to it.
I was like, that's not my idea.
My idea was this PR video
that I want to send out
to help me in this outreach.
But he was like, I'm
not interested in that.
So there was a little--
and I was, OK, let's do some--
I don't know-- video stories.
And he came to New York.
We filmed two of them.
And they not only
were a hit, they
are now the focus of
what I'm From Driftwood
what is today, which are these
weekly video stories that we
publish every Wednesday.
So it was all
because of Marquise,
who's now a board member.
I was like, oh, you
have really good ideas.
And so actually, do you
want to watch a video story?
MISTRAL MYERS: Yeah.
Yeah, let's do it.
So we've got a couple of
videos here for you to see.
So let me make sure
my clicker is working.
There we go.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Hi, my name is
Matt Beierschmitt.
I'm from Collinswood,
New Jersey.
And when I was 15 years old,
I was on my family computer
talking on AOL
chat rooms and just
to meet people and
meet other guys
and unbeknownst to
the rest of my family.
I'm in the
male-for-male chat room,
and I'm talking to this guy.
Back in the day, you maybe
got one picture from somebody.
It took like five minutes
for one picture to upload.
So you had to just
take what you can get.
I'm 15.
He's probably like in his
30s, and no one knows my age.
I'm telling him I'm older.
This guy's very eager to
meet me and just giving me
negative vibes, but I'm
desperate to meet somebody.
I wanted to just have a
connection with somebody.
So I just have a really
weird feeling about him.
So before I go to
meet him, I literally
have to sneak out of
my parents' house,
and I take a kitchen knife
with me just to be safe.
And I thought that would--
it was one of those old
'80s wood-handled kitchen
knives that wouldn't
cut a carrot,
but I thought it
would kill somebody.
So I take the kitchen
knife, go back to my room,
and I sneak out my first story
window, hop to the ground,
and I walk about a half mile
to this river near my parents'
house.
Told the guy what I was wearing,
and we agreed on the time
to meet.
And no cell phones, so
you have to tell them,
I'll meet you at this time,
and you just go down there
and wait.
So he picks me up, and we drive
to I think one of the parking
lots along the river.
And it's dark, and I'm
not really into him.
He's not hideous, but
just not really into him,
and he's in me.
And I've already
come all this way,
and so I feel obligated
to do something.
So I end up fooling
around with the guy,
and I was a little nervous.
But we end up fooling
around maybe 10 minutes.
And afterwards, I get out
of the car immediately,
and I just start heading home.
I don't know if it was that
night or the next night,
but I'm online again, and I
get an email from him saying,
it was nice to meet you.
You seem like a nice guy.
And you forgot your
knife in my car.
And I just was like
mortified, but also
didn't really care because
I was petrified at the time
and glad I brought it.
So fast forward to a
few months later, I'm
back in South Jersey
male-for-male chatting
with people, and I've been
chatting with this one guy
for a while, one
kid for a while.
I remember his screen
name was KegKiller,
and I was BlueSwoosh81.
That's my birthday,
and Nike was swoosh.
And we chatted for a
while, and I had a feeling
he was legit and real.
And the way we
chatted about stuff,
I knew he was my
age, lived nearby,
and I really wanted to meet him.
But he did not want to meet me.
He was very skeptical about
it, very scared about it.
But he actually dropped
where he worked randomly
in conversation one time.
It was a movie theater.
So I asked my friend Liz to
go to the movies with me,
and it was to go see
"Good Will Hunting,"
and I think it was like
in '96, '97 at this point,
and I knew it was at
his movie theater.
So I just randomly went
there one night to go see it.
And when I got there, the guy
taking my ticket resembled him.
He resembled his stats, and
I was like, OK, that's him.
That's him.
So we went to the movie,
got inside the movie,
and halfway through the
movie, I come back out,
and I make sure I buy--
I have some candy, and I
made sure I contact with him,
and I made sure that we had
some sort of interaction.
Not really talking, but
I made sure he saw me.
The next night or the night
after, I'm online again,
hoping he'll sign on so I can
tell him I went to his work.
And he ends up signing on, and
I end up chatting with him.
I'm like, hey, I
went to your work.
I think I saw you.
I was wearing this.
I said hi to you.
And he remembered me and
was willing to meet me now.
So we ended up meeting like
that night or night after.
I can't exactly I remember.
But from then on, we were
like instant friends,
and it was my first gay friend
ever I made, and we had so much
in common.
He lived near me.
He was in high school, too.
And I had like my
first gay friend
that I could do anything
with, and we ended up
just like going to the city
experiencing everything
together for the next 10 years.
And it was something
that I didn't
know I needed until I had it.
When I found Jeff, I was able
to be myself, be honest, just
be me.
When I was 15, I had
to find people online
because in 1996, there
wasn't anything else.
But today, I think it's
important to have safe spaces
where young queer youth can
go meet other people like them
so they're not
putting themselves
in these weird
predicaments like I
was meeting a complete stranger
down by the river with a knife.
It's funny now to think about
it, but it's also really scary.
And I don't want anybody
to be in that position.
So I think anybody who's young
in the closet or not even
in the closet but
still needs allies,
they need to find
safe spaces near them.
You need that.
You need people like you, going
through the same thing as you,
so you can make
mistakes with them,
learn from their mistakes,
and you help each other out.
It's important.
[END PLAYBACK]
MISTRAL MYERS:
[INAUDIBLE] Oh, OK.
I'm not as good at
this clicker thing
as I thought I was going to be.
So can you tell us a
little bit about this video
and why you decided to
include it in today's talk?
We have a couple others as
well, so got more to come.
NATHAN MANSKE:
Yeah, so early on,
I knew that I didn't want to--
or I knew a couple of things.
One is I wanted to make
sure that this was not
a coming out story site, and
it was very important to me
to share stories that capture
the queer experience as opposed
to this one moment
in everyone's life.
And so the only
prompt that I give
the storytellers is to share
a story from your life that's
meaningful to you
involving you being LGBTQ.
And some storytellers are like,
that's not very good direction.
[LAUGH] I'm like,
I intentionally
leave it very open.
I don't want to guide
you down any sort
of story or any
direction that might not
be your most meaningful story.
So we have a long list of
thought starter questions
to help people think of a
story they want to share.
So this story was--
we asked not to
think of a story.
And the process is we
email back and forth.
We send the storyteller
a link with the thought
starter questions and
a little form for them
to just get in
storytelling mode,
to set the stage of what
it's like, so they understand
that it's not a question
and answer interview.
It's not like a back and forth.
It's just sharing
their story with me.
And so this was just a story
that stuck out a lot to Matt.
So he shared it,
and we loved it.
And actually that reminds me
of another really valuable
learning experience that
I had very early on.
It was about
probably three weeks
after launching the website.
So it was very new, and
I was very inexperienced
and very protective
of I'm From Driftwood.
It's like it has to be
perfect and all this stuff.
But the only guidelines I had
were it has to be a story,
and it has to be
grammatically correct.
It was very, very loose.
So I would scan the stories
and make little grammar
and spelling fixes.
But if it was a story,
I would publish it.
So I received one story, and
this was a written story,
and the truth is, I just
didn't connect with it.
Whatever it was, I
wasn't feeling it.
And this was, again,
at a time where
I wanted to put I'm From
Driftwood's best face forward.
And so I started a
draft of an email
to the storyteller explaining
thank you for submitting.
Maybe rework it or
send another one.
And I couldn't articulate why
I didn't want to publish it,
and then I started feeling bad.
I'm like, what am
I going to say?
I don't like your story?
Like, sorry?
Who am I to say that?
So I was like, oh, whatever.
I'm just going to publish it.
So I published it, and one
of the very first comments
said this is the best story
I've read on the site.
And I'm so glad that
I learned that early
on because the reason it
didn't connect with me
is because I didn't need it to.
I have my life
and my experiences
and my history, and that story,
I didn't need that story,
but other people did.
So it allowed me to
really remove myself
and my personal experiences
from I'm From Driftwood.
And so whenever people come
up with a story like Matt,
that was a meaningful
story to him.
And it just so happens
that I connect with it
because I was definitely
on those AOL m-for-m chat
rooms also.
But that's why I
try to be hands off
in terms of helping people
think of their stories.
And some people
have many stories
that they're thinking about,
and then we'll talk to them
and help them develop them more.
MISTRAL MYERS:
Yeah, I think it's
really fascinating in an
archive like this the diversity
of experience that you find.
So I would encourage
everybody to go and take
a look at the site, which
has this video archive,
and you can really
find an enormous number
of different kinds of
stories from people
with very, very wide ranging
experiences of identifying
as LGBTQ in various stages of
their journey throughout life.
But I'm curious also if you
saw some recurring themes.
Did you have certain things that
kept circling up for you, even
as you were stepping away
from being personally invested
or connecting with every story?
Did you find that
interesting things were
popping up over and over again?
NATHAN MANSKE: Not
generally at first.
And it actually leads me to
talking about the story tour,
because at first, we were
collecting video stories
from people.
We had no money.
We had no organization.
It was just like
doing what we could.
So we had to do what
was easiest, which
was collect stories in
New York and Philadelphia
where Marquise lives.
And the good thing about
New York and Philly
is that they're such
international cities.
So people are from
everywhere here in New York.
So it was good because we were
getting some diverse stories,
but I felt like we were
cheating a little bit
because all the people
here decided to move here,
and that is a different kind of
person than people who decide
to stay in their hometowns.
So that was where the idea
of the 50 state story tour
came from.
I was like, we're doing a good
job of getting diverse stories,
but we need to
really get out there.
And so I pitched the
idea to Marquise,
and he had a nice, cushy job
in Philly, and, of course,
I'm scrambling to do
what I can to turn this
into an organization.
And so I'm like, let's
go to all 50 states.
And he's like, [LAUGH].
He's like, how is that possible?
Let's do like a five day, three
city tour in the Northeast.
Let's start there.
Build some interest.
And I was like, no, no, no.
No one's going to care about
a three city tour in over five
days.
We have to do it big.
It has to be I'm From
Driftwood's 50 state story
tour.
It has to be stories from
all over the country.
And about six months
later and a lot
of convincing and conversations,
we decided to do it
and bought a van,
mapped it all out, and--
MISTRAL MYERS: You
did it by vehicle?
NATHAN MANSKE: We drove.
MISTRAL MYERS: You were not
flying between the places.
OK.
NATHAN MANSKE: We flew
to Alaska and Hawaii.
We thought about
getting a duck van so we
could drive to Hawaii, but no.
So, yeah, we drove
to all 48 states
and then flew to Hawaii, from
Hawaii to Alaska, then back
to the 48 states.
And it took over four months.
And so to answer
your question, that
was when we noticed a trend.
I guess there's a trend I guess
of me setting rules for myself,
but I was like, I don't want
to seek out specific stories.
If we are in Laramie,
Wyoming, I don't
want to seek out a
Matt Shepard story.
If we're in the
South, I don't want
to seek out religious stories.
If we're in Utah, I don't
want to see Mormon stories.
I just wanted the stories to
happen and stick to our guns
and say whatever story
you want to share.
And I'm glad we did
that because that
is the best way to notice
a trend without swaying
it any certain way.
And the trend was something
that I didn't predict.
We did presentations,
like story sharing events
at colleges and universities,
and whenever I did,
I would ask people
there, what is
it like being LGBTQ
here in Kansas?
And the answers consistently
were the smaller
the town, the more
the youth or community
wanted to challenge
the perception
of the rest of the country
about their small town.
And they're like, just
because we're in a small town
doesn't mean we're backwoods
idiots, knuckle draggers.
My family's supportive of me.
I'm out at school.
Like, they were
really challenging
this perception of Kansas
or wherever we were
being this terrible small town.
They're like, it's not that way.
We don't have protections.
They were very honest
and real about it,
but they were like, they
hear I'm from Kansas,
and they think, oh, it
must be so terrible.
And there are rooms
for improvement,
but it's not this
terrible place to be.
And then the opposite was
true in the big cities--
the same but opposite.
So it was we were in West
Hollywood at the LA Center,
and it's West Hollywood,
like the gayest of the gay.
And there was probably 18
or maybe even 16 to 24.
A youth group had a meeting,
and we shared stories,
and I almost didn't ask.
Because it's this
beautiful-- like,
there's so much money
behind it in their center,
and it was new and renovated.
But I was like, I should ask.
I was like, what's it like being
LGBTQ here in West Hollywood?
And all their hands
shot up, and they're
like, just because we're
in West Hollywood doesn't
mean it's easy.
And I don't live
in West Hollywood.
I live with my parents.
I had to sneak out to be here.
They don't know I'm gay.
My friend was kicked out.
So it was the same
idea of challenging
a perception of what
the world sees them as
and turning that on its head.
And basically, everyone
was saying, we're unique.
There's not a broad
stroke that you
can paint for our town or city.
It was like pay
attention to us--
to us, not our town or city.
So that was the biggest trend
I saw on the story tour.
MISTRAL MYERS: That's
really good to hear.
I'm glad that that was the
trend and not something
worse or more difficult.
NATHAN MANSKE: Yeah.
MISTRAL MYERS:
Yeah, good to hear
that people were able to
challenge their perceptions
of their small towns.
As somebody who grew up
in a relatively small town
in the middle of New
Mexico, which at the time
was probably also a place in
which people would imagine it
being not particularly
LGBTQ friendly,
I actually didn't want to
challenge those perceptions
so much because I
think at the time,
it was still a pretty
difficult place to grow up.
But I can understand
the impetus--
[INAUDIBLE] give a
real understanding
for folks who don't
live there of what
it's actually like to be from
that place as an LGBTQ person.
NATHAN MANSKE: Yeah.
Yeah, I feel like
there's a balance.
People are like,
yeah, there's pride.
It's like, I'm from here.
I like it.
I love it.
There are some issues, but, hey.
It's not all the way
one or the other.
There is a balance, and yeah.
MISTRAL MYERS: That's great.
At what point did
you start to have
an understanding of where
you needed to broaden out
your demographics?
So you were talking
in particular
about looking at the stories
of older LGBTQ folks is often
a part of our community that
can be either not properly cared
for, not properly highlighted,
or sometimes even silenced
in a variety of ways.
So using that as
an example, where
was the fork in
the road where you
realized that broadening
demographics would
be really helpful?
NATHAN MANSKE:
Pretty early on, we
knew that we wanted to make sure
that the stories represented
the diversity of the community,
which there's no community more
diverse than the LGBT
community because we're
part of every community.
So it was always a focus, but
it wasn't until we would--
so the process is we
help storytellers come up
with a single story to
share from their life.
And what would
happen whenever we
would get a story from
somebody who's older
is that we would work
with them on the phone
and figure out a single story,
and we would show up to film.
And let's say, for example, the
story's about they found love
at age 50.
But then we show up
with the cameras,
and they're like, when I was
14, and I was like, what?
Wait.
We're looking at
my notes like, uh.
And they try to cram in their
entire life into this story,
and we try to keep the videos
about five minutes, five
to six minutes, because we want
to make sure people watch them.
And if we upload
a 25 minute video,
it's unlikely people are going
to watch the whole thing.
So there's this
balance of needing
to have shareable and viewable
content while making sure
that we respect the
storyteller and the story they
want to share.
So with elders, then we
felt bad because we'd
publish their story and they're
like, what about this and this
and this that I talked about?
And we're like, it was too long.
We don't think people
would watch it.
So they would be a
little sad by that,
and we feel like
we let them down.
So we wanted to
come up with a way
to have this compromise of
like, what can we do to--
and also elders have no
one in the community ever
will see as much history
and change in the community
as our elders right now.
They have been arrested
for dancing with people
of the same gender,
and now they can
marry people of the
same gender, and that
won't exist in 20 years, and
it didn't exist 20 years ago.
And so we also knew the
importance and value
of documenting and
preserving their history.
So we came up with
this new program called
What Was It Like,
and it's specifically
stories of LGBTQ elders.
And the way that
program works is
that instead of having
them share one story,
we helped them figure out six
to eight individual stories
in their life.
So it's still every
story has an arc.
Every story has an individual
conflict and resolution
so then we can share
them individually.
But it also gives
them the opportunity
to share their
whole life but still
through individual stories.
So we launched that about
a year and a half ago,
and it's been incredible.
I mean, we talk a lot
behind the scenes.
But even Damien, my colleague
and the videographer
and editor, he says the
stories from elders,
they're just
better, because they
have such different
history, and younger people
have fewer stories
to choose from.
So it's really been just
an incredible new program
that we're happy with.
And we have a story from an
elder if we're ready to watch.
MISTRAL MYERS: Yes.
NATHAN MANSKE: We're
going to skip Alexa's.
MISTRAL MYERS: We're
going to have to skip?
NATHAN MANSKE: Yeah.
MISTRAL MYERS: OK.
So give me just one
second to do my clicker.
There we go.
NATHAN MANSKE: There it was.
MISTRAL MYERS: Here it is.
NATHAN MANSKE: All right.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- In 1997, give or
take a year or two,
I was working out
on Fire Island,
a barrier island
off of Long Island,
and I worked at this little
restaurant called El Hot Spot.
It was a Mexican restaurant with
a generic name, a Mexican name.
And I was told that I could
wear anything I wanted,
and, in fact, they encouraged
me to dress up, be myself.
I was wearing a church
dresses with hats sometimes,
all different kinds of wigs.
And I didn't know
much about makeup,
but I had some girlfriends
that started to help me
with the makeup and stuff.
I was given this
creative freedom.
I had basically
lived as a gay man,
and Pearl hadn't emerged yet.
And so I was wearing--
I just tried to put together
things that I could find.
They had a lot of--
I was wearing--
they would have--
a lot of the old drag queens
out on the island would retire
and their drag, and they
would put it up at yard sales,
and I would go shopping.
That's where I did my
shopping in the beginning
because I dare not go to any
store to buy women's clothing.
And so I was getting ready
to come into the city,
and I was going to go
through my whole routine,
put on back into
my male clothing,
and get ready to come back.
Simple, I've done
it a thousand times.
And at that time, I
couldn't get it together.
I couldn't change my clothes,
and I couldn't get out
of my drag to go
back into the city,
and I felt so schizophrenic.
And I started talking to myself.
I said, OK now, Pearl.
Come on off it.
Or I might have
even talk to Ken.
I said, OK.
Chop, chop.
Let's get it together.
Let's get on that boat,
take off these clothes.
And it was like Pearl
came out of me and said,
I'm not taking them off.
It was like, I said, what?
And she said, I'm not
taking this dress off.
And I'm holding a
conversation with myself.
I sad, of course you are.
I said, we can't go.
And so I went up
to the Ice Palace,
and I remember talking to one
of the entertainers there.
I said, I'm going back into
the city just like this.
And he said, no, Pearl.
You got to take it off
because you could be beat up.
Or you could--
I said, Pearl won't let
me take the drag off.
I know he probably
said, this child's
been doing a little
too many drugs.
So I ran home, got
my bag, got my stuff,
and I got on the boat.
It was the most surreal trip
across the bay from Cherry
Grove back to Sayville.
And I'm on the way in,
and people are looking.
And I look just like what I am.
And I go in, and I remember
walking through Penn Station,
and I'm in a flowing something.
And people-- and when
I looked in my wake,
you know how you
walk past somebody
and if you look back
real quick in your wake,
there's all these people
staring like, what?
And I get on the subway,
and I catch the train
on back down this way.
Now it's getting ready to
just throw everything out
that I thought I was--
a gay black man living with HIV.
And now this new,
new something has
emerged that was peeking
out all the time.
Pearl was there.
She didn't have a name,
but she was there.
Everything up to this point had
led to me being true to myself
as a transgender woman,
and at that point,
I had no idea what that meant.
Because for the next 16 years,
and it still continue today,
it's been a journey.
And I wouldn't trade
it for the world.
[END PLAYBACK]
MISTRAL MYERS: So clearly,
a lot of these stories,
again, it's just
really wonderful
being able to see each of
these stories on the archive.
It's such an
incredible experience
to jump into other
people's lives,
all those mirror neurons
getting fired up.
But I'm curious.
This actually leaves us
really nicely into part
of what you came
here to talk about,
which was having all of
this be a digital platform
and have it be an internet
base, particularly
when we're talking about
LGBTQ elders who may have told
stories prior to this becoming
an easy platform to access
in very different ways.
So I'm curious how you
see that playing in
and influencing this
project at its core.
NATHAN MANSKE: Yeah,
I mean, it simply
wouldn't exist if we weren't
in the internet age right now
and without YouTube and ways
to share all these stories,
because our focus
has always been
on getting these stories out
to a home in Idaho somewhere.
That's what makes I'm
From Driftwood special
I think is its accessibility--
freely accessible to anyone
with an internet connection.
And that's what's
special about it.
We look at our analytics,
and most of our views
do come from the
bigger states, but just
knowing that they've been
seen from every country
in the world.
I mean, I can't understate it.
It wouldn't exist without where
we are today with the internet.
And the name itself, it's town
focused, geography focused.
It's really all about getting
our stories out there.
That said, there
is an element of--
I don't know.
It becomes a little bit
impersonal especially for me
because I spend so much
time on just like a computer
sharing these stories,
and it becomes so digital
that it loses a little
bit of heart sometimes.
And I can't tell if that's just
me because it's my job or what.
But because of that, we started
having more community events
where we screen stories
in public places,
and we have
storyteller spotlights.
So Pearl, for example, was
one of our first featured
storyteller spotlights, where
we screen a few of her stories
and she's there
with a moderator,
and there's questions
from the audience.
So you see these stories,
and then you can actually
ask the storyteller questions.
So it kind of takes it offline.
So as much as we're focusing
on online, we're now--
I think maybe as
humans in general,
we've been so focused on
online and digital and phones.
Now we're like, wait.
I missed this
personal connection.
And we're correcting
that a little bit.
So I'm glad that we now have
these ways of experiencing
I'm From Driftwood offline.
So, yeah.
MISTRAL MYERS: Having to
complement is really cool.
So online storytelling
clearly doesn't
have a very long history,
certainly not in comparison
to storytelling more broadly.
So we don't have a ton
of precedent to go off.
But I'm curious as somebody who
is involved on a daily basis
in curating LGBTQ stories
in the online space,
do you have a sense for
how online storytelling
particularly around LGBT
stories is going to develop
over the next five, 10 years?
What do you see coming up
for online storytelling?
NATHAN MANSKE: I think
just generally it's
going to become decentralized,
and we're actually
trying to put together
a youth committee
to help us figure out--
because nine years is a
long time for the internet.
So much has changed.
Instagram didn't
exist when we started.
So what I want to
figure out is what
I'm From Driftwood would look
like today if it started today.
And it would probably not
be a centralized website.
It would be more of a
hashtag or something,
and it's not all
living on one place.
It's everywhere.
And you can look at
the #MeToo movement.
That is not a
centralized storytelling,
and it's a singular theme,
and it's everywhere.
There's not a single
place to go there.
I think storytelling is
going to become decentralized
I guess is maybe a dry
answer, but I think
that's like where it's going.
Just the internet in
general, it's less--
you look at blogs now.
There are not as many blogs.
People don't go to places
like bookmarks and stuff.
It's now just what
you read on Instagram
or Facebook or Twitter.
I feel like everything's been
taken and shaken up and just
like thrown out there.
So I think it's going to be
similar for storytelling.
MISTRAL MYERS: Interesting.
How do you find navigating
that space knowing it's
becoming decentralized?
And clearly there are lots
of options for where folks
can go to find LGBTQ stories.
So do you find it a
challenge to try and get
I'm From Driftwood into
a unique enough space
that it's still
holding its own in what
can be just a competitive,
as you say, decentralized
space on the internet?
NATHAN MANSKE: Yeah,
the challenge for us
is we're trying to plan
five years in advance
and 10 years in advance.
And looking back,
it's like, oh my god,
five years ago,
things change so fast.
And we're applying for
funding for something
that we're planning for
in a couple of years.
But then if you get the funding,
it's like, wait, actually,
we need to change
this because of this.
And it is just very fast
paced environment obviously,
but that's a good thing.
So that's not a complaint.
It's just that it is
a challenge though.
And just trying to always keep
up with it and stay relevant.
Is a website the way to go?
Do we need 20 second
video stories?
And actually, we've
been tracking--
YouTube has
analytics that allows
you to monitor the percentage
of the video watched,
and early on, we
were very focused
on less than three minutes.
We kind of made it up but also
looked, did some research.
We're like, less than three
minutes for a video story.
And then we got a
really great story
that had to be closer
to four minutes.
We're like, OK, just this once.
But we compared those
analytics, and we're
like, look, the same percentage
of people watched it.
And now some of our videos
are over seven minutes,
and the percentage
stays the same.
So that just taught us
that the story arc takes
the primary focus, and
as long as it's a story,
people watch it
for the same amount
of time or percentage of time
as they would for a two minute
story.
So yeah.
I forget how I got
there, but I think--
MISTRAL MYERS: No, no,
that's really interesting.
I know that that's not the case
for all YouTube videos, right?
Plenty of them, you
drop off in the middle.
So it's really interesting
to hear that LGBT stories are
really connecting, particularly
that arc is keeping
people engaged over the course.
I'm sure on the keeping up
with the technology piece,
I know that as I get
older and more crotchety,
it's actually really
difficult to keep up
with the new
technologies that are
coming out and
understanding how they work.
Like, Snapchat is just
a thing that I just
do not understand nor use.
Yes, it came along
with my gray hairs.
So I can imagine that
that is difficult,
but it's a really
interesting space to be in.
NATHAN MANSKE: It's
the youth committee.
I'm like, we'll just
get the youth to do it.
MISTRAL MYERS: That's good.
So I know that we had one
more video we wan to show,
which we certainly can.
But before we jump into
getting some questions from
the audience and certainly
showing this last video
if we'd like to, I just want to
make sure that we touch on how
groups like ours-- so the
Gayglers is Google's LGBTQ
employee resource group--
and how groups
like the Gayglers,
as well as other LGBTQ community
groups or organizations,
can become involved with
a project like this,
either with the option
to contribute or help
spread the word, et cetera.
NATHAN MANSKE: Yeah.
There are so many ways.
We're a very small organization,
and we have very big goals
of what we're trying to do.
And it's just me and Damien.
So one is share your story.
From what I've heard,
it's a good process.
It's a learning process.
You learn about storytelling.
We come to you to
film your story.
So just reach out to us--
nathan@imfromdriftwood.com--
and we will get your story.
If you don't live here, we can
sometimes find videographers
in your area.
But sharing your story,
there's no better way
to get to know more
about the organization
than sharing your story.
We have community events.
We are volunteer opportunities.
We have this youth committee.
So if you're knowledgeable
on all of these new--
we need help with Instagram.
And also, it's just like time.
I'm trying to keep Instagram
up to date with our stories
and photos, and we need help
and guidance, so social media.
AdWords, we have a Google grant,
and AdWords is so in-depth,
and, yeah, it's way beyond
what I am able to do.
So we need help with that.
We need help with anything.
So basically, if you
are interested in taking
part and volunteering
at events or anything
at all with a
storytelling organization,
just reach out to me,
and we will make sure
that you're doing
something that you enjoy.
MISTRAL MYERS: That's great.
I think that in the
interest of time
we might open it up now for Q&A
unless there is anything else
that you wanted to
touch on before we jump
into some audience questions.
NATHAN MANSKE: No,
that sounds great.
MISTRAL MYERS: OK, great.
Does anybody have any questions?
Yes, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I took a brief look
at your website,
and from that and from
what you've shown here,
you highlight, for example,
transgender stories, gender
non-binary stories.
You showed a story
of a community elder,
though I didn't see a way
to particularly access
that on your website.
And it got me wondering
whether there are tools there
that I just didn't see that
allow people to explore
the site from the point
of view of various kinds
of intersectionality.
NATHAN MANSKE: Yes.
So basically, we tag
all of our stories.
I have like a traffic jam in
my mind of what I want to say.
So we are working on
a new tool right now,
which we need help with from
smart developers and encoders
and all that stuff that
we don't know how to do,
where we want to create what's
currently called a story map,
and it's a visual representation
of I'm From Driftwood.
So it's literally this
globe, and there's
a visual representation
of every single story
that we've collected,
and it's interactive.
So you can click on
it, and it pulls up
a preview of the story, and
you can filter those by our
What Was It Like stories.
You can filter it by
transgender stories, sexuality,
gender orientation,
or gender identity.
So that is stepping
in that direction
of making it easier
to search and find
the stories that you want.
The website itself right
now is not ideal for that.
You can go to the search
bar and type in New Mexico,
and all the New Mexico
stories will come up.
But it's not
perfectly there yet.
But the story map
is my answer for all
that because then you
can search for anything,
and it's right there.
You see this globe, and it
pulls up all those stories,
and you can zoom in and see.
It's really cool, but we
have to get it to a place
where we can publish it, and
it's not quite there yet.
And additionally, the
What Was It Like stories,
we want to create a companion
site that lives on I'm
From Driftwood but feels
like its own thing also,
so that if you want to only look
at What Was It Like stories,
you can go there,
and all their stories
are presented in this way.
Like, Pearl has
six other stories.
So a way to watch
that one story we
just watched but know that there
are other stories from Pearl
right there that you
can just click on next.
So, yes, we need help
with website development
and that story map.
So reach out.
Yeah.
Did I answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
NATHAN MANSKE: OK great.
MISTRAL MYERS: Great.
I also want to note that
Googlers who are either
watching this video or
here in the room can
in their own personal capacity
outside of work certainly
offer their stories
to I'm With Driftwood,
and we're happy to help connect
you as volunteers with Nathan
in order to get those stories
up if that would be something
that would be of interest.
Does anyone else have
any questions for Nathan
while we're here?
Yeah.
Raheem, if you don't mind
just popping up to the mic
so we can capture you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Nathan.
My name's Raheem.
Quick question, so you said
so you host sometimes on site
events to help with the cause.
I wanted to know, so how do
you decide what type of events
to help build community?
Where did you go
for those resources?
Or do you just
develop that yourself?
NATHAN MANSKE: Yeah,
we basically just--
we knew that we wanted
to take it offline,
and we've been operating
for nine years.
I mean, we know that we have
a lot of supporters and fans
because whenever we have
fundraisers, people show up.
But that eliminates a lot of
the rest of the community who
likes I'm From Driftwood
if you have to pay
$100 to go to a fundraiser.
So we wanted an
option for anyone
to participate and come
and be part of the I'm
From Driftwood community.
So all of our community
events are free,
and typically, they're
like happy hour
times at bars and more
generally community spaces.
And later in March, we
have our anniversary party
at Stonewall upstairs.
In April, we have a storyteller
spotlight club coming.
So we're trying to
target different age
groups and different
people in the community
just by having fun events.
And also, just last week, I
spoke at CUNY here in New York.
They have an LGBT student group.
So some are college campuses.
Some are like at bars
and community centers.
We had an event at the
Center several years ago.
Yeah, so really the objective
was to take it offline
and get all these
people who know
about I'm From Driftwood
together in a room,
as opposed to just commenting
on Facebook or whatever.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I see what you're saying.
And last question, so how do
you keep them coming back?
NATHAN MANSKE: It
depends on what it--
like, people to
go to the events?
AUDIENCE: Mm-hmm.
NATHAN MANSKE: Our newsletter.
[LAUGH] And good drink
specials at the bars.
But really, we had an event.
The last one that we
had featured-- his name
is Robert Richards, and it was
a What Was It Like storyteller.
It was one of the most
incredible experiences,
like seeing him
watch his stories.
He had not seen them, and we
published it over a year ago.
So we got to see him
watch his own stories.
And at one point, he
was like, wait, stop.
It was about a former lover,
and he was like, stop.
I can't.
And then the moderator
asked some questions,
and he talked about it.
He was like, OK, OK, I'm good.
Let's finish the video.
Finished it, and he was like,
that was just-- you just
have this emotion and
raw emotion in the room.
And I think that's what gets
people really coming back.
They see the emotions that
come out from these stories
and also seeing a
storyteller there.
So for the storyteller
spotlights,
it's just this powerful
experience to witness
and to hear stories and an
interview from our elders.
So my hope is that people who
go to these experience that,
these feelings, and
come back for more.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MISTRAL MYERS: Thanks, Raheem.
Have any other questions?
Anyone brave that I
can see out there?
If not, then, Nathan, thank
you so much for being here.
We're so delighted to have I'm
From Driftwood here at Google
and to be able to hear about the
process and the journey for you
and also how we
can get involved.
So we will definitely look
forward to seeing you again.
But really appreciate it.
Let's give him a round
of applause, shall we?
[APPLAUSE]
NATHAN MANSKE: Thank you.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Play the third video.
MISTRAL MYERS: You want
to play the third video?
OK.
NATHAN MANSKE: We've got it.
Might as well.
MISTRAL MYERS: We've got it.
It's right here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- My name is Alexa Espinal,
and I'm from New York City.
I recently came to Mississippi
four months ago to teach.
I'm teaching middle school art.
So I teach six through seven--
I mean, sixth, seventh,
and eighth grade.
It's been eight weeks now,
and it was interesting being
a young person-- right, because
I'm obviously very young--
and coming from New York
City and then asserting
this kind of power and
being in this place
where you are not really
connected to the culture.
Plus, I don't necessarily--
I am a colored person but
don't racially identify with--
they still don't know what I am.
And in the state, it's kind
of very black and white.
And the in-between is strange.
And for students, it's hard
for them to gauge that.
So it's my second
week of school.
I'm still figuring out how
to navigate this new realm
that I'm in, right?
This new place, new position.
And I have to walk all
the students in a line
to the bathroom.
So there's some waiting time.
And as other students
are using the bathroom,
these two students break out
in a fight kind of, not a fight
but just like a tiff
between the two.
And they're like, you're
gay, you're gay, you're gay.
And I was just like,
how do I address
this knowing that
I can get fired
for being gay in Mississippi?
Which is like a huge thing.
And then on top of that,
knowing that there's
this religious thing.
How do I then say
anything about it?
But I knew I had
to say something.
Something needed to be said.
So I was like, we're
not going to speak
about being gay in a negative
way because it's not negative,
and we're not going to use
that word in that kind of way.
We're not going to
use that language.
And this one kid straightened
up, looks forward,
and he's like, OK, I'm
not going to do it.
Then this other student blurts
out, well, no, it's a sin.
Being gay's a sin.
It's wrong.
And I didn't know what
to say at that point.
And I just knew that I couldn't
push too much, especially
since it's my second week.
Like, I'm not trying to
cause huge waves either.
And I was just like,
well, we're not
using that word in a
negative way and just
shut it down there.
So he just straightened
up, and we ended up
going back to the classroom.
Time passes on, and I still hear
it every again in the hallway.
And the first time I saw
maybe like a small light
was this one kid decided
to say it in my classroom.
The word comes up again,
and these two boys
start saying, you're
gay, you're gay.
And all I did was give a look.
And this one student
says, we're not
using that type of language.
And I was like,
yeah, that's amazing.
And I'm planting a seed, and
something's happening, right?
There's going to be
change, and it's just
going to take some time.
I think it's important
to always respect
where people come
from and understand
that everybody has a
different background,
has different beliefs.
And so the only way to really
create any type of change
is to meet them where they
are, meet them with they know,
and try to not change
the way that they think,
but maybe change the
framing of what they've
seen, especially when you're
dealing with young students,
right?
So by not reprimanding
him in a kind of way
or saying like you're
wrong, just saying
that's not the word to use.
We're not using that
word in a negative way,
and that word isn't negative.
And hopefully, students
will feel a lot more calm--
any students that
are maybe struggling
with sexual identity,
that they can
see that they can come to me.
I'm an ally.
I'm someone that
they can speak to.
[END PLAYBACK]
MISTRAL MYERS: [INAUDIBLE]
That was a nice way to end.
NATHAN MANSKE: Thanks, everyone.
MISTRAL MYERS: All right.
[APPLAUSE]